you mentioned psychology and taking us
back to the Magnus even in 2010 the
magnus games but Reddit said that you've
spoken about losing to Magnus being a
hit on your confidence uh is there some
uh truth to that some is there some
aspect about that 2010 match that's not
just about Magnus figuring stuff out but
just a hit on confidence like how
important is confidence at that level
when you're both young and like firing
at all cylinders well it's not just a
problem to me this is the problem
everybody against Magnus because what
happens is is on a broader level when
you're playing on somebody no matter who
you're playing against but when they're
somehow able to save positions where
they're much worse almost in miraculous
ways the way that Magnus is done against
everybody he's done it against me done
against aronian many times done it
against cramming just about everybody
when when someone's able to save games
it really starts to affect you because
you don't know what to do and more and
more the more more times that happens it
starts adding up and it just affects you
in a way that it's very very hard to
overcome and I think every top player
has that issue where if they've played
against Magnus more than like five times
they've seen things happen in the game
that don't happen against anybody else
and then psychologically it becomes
harder and harder to overcome it which
is why I think a lot of the junior
players they don't have this long
history and it does affect them as far
as myself directly
um certainly after that match though it
was not the same playing against Magnus
because I viewed him completely
differently too after all his games
where he was saving these these end
games I started think like this guy is
superhuman but you can't really have
those thoughts when you're playing
competitively but in the back of your
mind it's always there and I think every
top player has that issue is there a way
to overcome that because you have to I
don't know if I'll necessarily do better
against Magnus going forward but I felt
that when I started playing against him
more than just a game here or there in
classical chess during the pandemic I
played in these online tournaments it
seemed like every month
um I came very close I beat him in one
event I think I lost and two others and
then the two are final but when I was
playing against them more and more if he
didn't feel superhuman it felt like as
I'm playing more and more and learning
about his style
um that I was doing better so I think
for me the weird thing is that I just
wasn't playing against him that many
games but when I started playing against
like 20 30 games during the course of a
year I actually started feeling more
confident because I feel like I can
compete whereas when I was only playing
him like three or four times in
classical chess in the previous couple
of years
it what I wasn't doing great and then
you don't have you don't have those
glimpses of you don't have those moments
where you feel like you're going to be
able to win against them but when you
start playing 20 30 games and you get
these opportunities even if you don't
convert you feel like you have the
chances when you play three or four
games and there you might lose one draw
three you never have those opportunities
and so you feel very negative about
what's going on when you were able to
beat them or not necessarily win the
game but when positionally something uh
what was the reason like
technically speaking
the matchup between the two of you what
like where where are the holes that you
were able to find I mean the the answer
I think is actually quite simple I think
it's all psychological actually more
than anything else
um
because I didn't it didn't I didn't feel
like I was doing anything differently
but I was also not making the mistakes
that I was making before
um so I think it was more psychological
than on your part versus his part it's
it's very weird because when you when
you think about Chess it's a mental game
um you know but we we all are capable of
beating Magnus all of us but we all have
very very bad scores against him and I
think people underestimate how much of a
role that plays
um and for me when I played him in these
online events in 2020 specifically I
felt like there there was really nothing
to lose which also ties into everything
else that happened um during the
pandemic as well but I just feel like
there was nothing to lose and I felt
like I was playing very freely unlike
unlike before now that's not to say that
Magnus isn't a better player that like
somehow I expect to beat him but I felt
like I wasn't making the same mistakes
that I was making in the previous years